[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 60,18 bienvenue pour cette
édition du journal du lundi 15 juin
voici les titres
le feu vert a été donné hier soir par le
président de la république après les
terrasses les bars cafés et restaurants
peuvent rouvrir totalement depuis
aujourd'hui en ile-de-france un
soulagement pour les professionnels du
secteur
reportage à montigny le bretonneux autre
annonce des manuels macron l'école
redeviendra obligatoire dès le 22 juin
pour tous les élèves de maternelle et
d'élémentaire et du collège et les
établissements ont une semaine pour se
préparer la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles s'est déplacé cet après midi
à vélizy villacoublay
et en attendant le retour en classe
pourquoi ne pas profiter d'une histoire
contée les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en proposant
en ligne en ce moment elle est
bibliothécaire se sont prêtés au jeu
interview ce dimanche emmanuel macron a
donc dévoilé les conditions de la
nouvelle phase de déconfinement l'île de
france passe en zone verte et les cafés
bars et restaurants peuvent donc rouvrir
entièrement un protocole strict est
néanmoins respecter pour les
restaurateurs qui sont plutôt satisfaits
d'accueillir leurs clients à nouveau en
salle exemple à montigny le bretonneux
avec mathilde et demi et aureilhan ce en
salle ou en terrasse
les restaurateurs peuvent à présent
reposer cette fameuse question
suite aux annonces des manuels macron
même si le temps n'est pas encore au
beau fixe
la réouverture des salles divise la
clientèle sera que c'est quand même plus
agréable de s'asseoir de se poser de
manger sur place mais c'est mieux d'être
dehors je pense c'est à dire libre
partie nous manque les gestes barrières
sont respectés la distance
respectez donc ceux là ya pas de en
terrasse ou intérieure se passe pas un
problème
surpris par les annonces du président ce
restaurateur de montigny le bretonneux a
eu à peine le temps de se préparer pour
la réouverture
il a rappelé dimanche soir c'est aux
salariés pour revenir travailler à temps
plein ce lundi matin
pour nous c'est un soulagement de
pouvoir ouvrir on attendait depuis
tellement longtemps de retrouver un peu
une vie normale néanmoins quand même
d'ouvrir en prévenant on peut s'arrêter
n'aurait pu s'organiser mieux nous on
travaille essentiellement quasiment que
des produits frais donc pour
s'approvisionner c'est pas évident une
table sur deux est occupé par des
clients et sur ses deux salles une seule
est ouverte ce qui représente 40
couverts sur 80 depuis le 2 juin il a dû
investir pour pouvoir accueillir plus de
monde en terrasse va terrasse derrière
je peux mettre beaucoup de monde mais
comme nos clients ne savaient pas et que
la copropriété a nous a alloué sept
espaces et que le temps de d'acheter le
matériel parce que grand une fois quand
vous allez faire des achats pour une
terrasse vous n'avez pas forcément tout
l'équipement forcément notre activité
est très impacté
en tout cas on espère des si la fin
d'année retrouvez un écran
fonctionnement plutôt normal pour ouvrir
totalement les restaurateurs devront
respecter un protocole strict 10 clients
maximum par table
rendre le port du masque obligatoire
pour se déplacer dans le restaurant et
espacer les tables d'un mètre autre
annonce du président de la république le
retour de tous les élèves dans les
écoles et collèges qui sera obligatoire
à partir de lundi prochain le 22 juin
est les écoles se préparent déjà la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
charline avenel c'est à déplacer à
vélizy-villacoublay cet après midi sur
place manon faraldo et mélanie pocus à
l'école élémentaire mozart de
vélizy-villacoublay ont préparé la
réouverture dans cet établissement d'une
capacité totale de 280 élèves il y a
actuellement 145 élèves par jour
la reprise totale est prévue le 22 juin
à quelques semaines seulement de la fin
de l'année scolaire
c'est toujours utile d'en voir ses
élèves oui
on attend juste les directives et puis
ça va le faire cette reprise se prépare
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
charline avenel et présente pour
expliquer l'organisation de cette fin
d'année le retour des élèves va être
préparé durant toute cette semaine le
protocole sanitaire sera donc allégé au
lieu d'avoir au moins un mètre entre
chaque bureau il y aura un mètre entre
chaque élève donc voyez ça permet de
lever la contrainte de 10 par classe en
maternelle de 15 en élémentaire et donc
de réunir davantage d'enfants de la même
manière les enfants auront le droit de
revenir dans la course jouer avec des
ballons c'est sans doute la mesure qui
acte le plus concrètement le retour à la
vie normale pour les enfants
oh mon foot je serai un peu compliqué
c'est que après si on en va pas être
dans les mains il faut désinfecter tous
et ça me fait un peu bizarre ce que j'ai
été habitué à être dans une classe de 10
et du coup ça doit être un changement il
y aura moins de jacques barré a donc ça
va être ça va beaucoup changer cet après
midi une grande réunion était organisée
par jean michel blanquer les principaux
syndicats du secteur pour que le
protocole soient expliquées et ajuster
puisqu'on parle de vélizy-villacoublay
on a appris aujourd'hui la disparition
de raymond loisel l'ancien maire de la
ville pendant quatorze ans entre 1990 et
2004 il a été à l'origine de nombreux
projets construction de la crèche des
lutins du centre d'art de l'undd et il a
défendu également le dossier du tramway
comme conseiller régional pascal
thévenot maire actuel qui a été dans sa
majorité lui a rendu hommage sur le site
internet de vélizy tout comme valérie
pécresse sur son compte twitter la
présidente de la région ile de france a
fait part de son immense tristesse c'est
aux côtés de raymond loisel qu'elle
avait commencé sa carrière politique
raymond l'oise elle avait 90 mesure
également de la nouvelle phase de
déconfinement cela a été confirmé
aujourd'hui à partir de demain il ne
sera plus nécessaire de se munir d'une
attestation employeur dans les
transports en commun aux heures de
pointe en ile de france est la
préfecture de région l'a indiqué à la
mi-journée en revanche le port du masque
reste obligatoire pendant plusieurs
semaines encore
l'île de france qui passe donc au vert
sur la carte du déconfinement une
épidémie qui est en recul tout comme
dans le département des yvelines au
dernier point de la rs un seul foyer
d'infection demeure on ne connaît ni la
localisation ni le nombre de malades
concernés
le département a compté jusqu'à dix
cluster pendant la crise sur le
territoire 509 personnes sont mortes à
l'hôpital
un décès en plus pendant le week end 477
est toujours hospitalisé hier dimanche
soit 7 ans - entre vendredi et dimanche
l 26 patients sont encore en réanimation
dans les yvelines 2028 personnes ont été
guéries de la cofidis
après un passage à l'hôpital parce que
c'est une des professions médicales les
plus exposés les dentistes ont fortement
diminué leurs activités pendant les huit
semaines de confinement prodiguant
seulement des soins d'urgence
aujourd'hui les 1030 quatre praticiens
du département ont repris leur
consultation à un rythme quasi normal
marqué par des règles d'hygiène
renforcées mélanie poké aurélie rond et
nicolas baudry pour ce dentiste
guyancourt toi les soins ont repris
comme avant le coc vide ou presque
le nombre de consultations quotidiennes
et réduit de moitié
l'organisation a été revu je les
installe très rapidement dans cette
pièce masqué et j'attends éventuellement
au moins 20 minutes entre entre la fin
de ma décontamination faire le nettoyage
complet rinçage nettoyage des surfaces
etc
si surtout j'ai utilisé des airs au sol
des aérosols ou c'est à dire une turbine
que j'essaye d'éviter d'utiliser et bien
des tarterêts
comme de nombreux praticiens ce dentiste
a totalement fermé son cabinet à
l'annonce du confinement avant de se
porter volontaires pour assurer les
urgences avait plus du tout de matériel
j'entends lui matériel c'est plutôt les
masques ffp2 qui nous posait des
problèmes encore peu en ce qui nous
concerne j'avais beaucoup de matériel
parce que je fais de la chirurgie et que
je fais d'enseignement au niveau de la
chirurgie on a été approvisionné avant
les gardes par le conseil de l'ordre n'a
donc on a les dents à versailles de
trois jours avant pour aller chercher
notre matériel et surtout préparer les
salles plus de 270 chirurgiens dentistes
ont été mobilisés durant le confinement
rage de dents traumatisme et hémorragies
ont été les principales causes de soins
nous avons institué un système de garde
sept jours sur sept avec des régulateurs
pour pouvoir enregistrer les appels de
patients et les régulateurs distribués
sur trois voire quatre voire cinq
binômes de léran faut savoir que dans
les binômes de garde
nous avions ce n'était que deux
chirurgiens dentistes puisque les
assistantes ne pouvait pas bien entendu
exercer le numéro d'urgence a été
composé plus de 5200 fois en 45 jours
depuis le déconfinement les 1030 quatre
praticiens ont repris leur activité dans
le département
dans l'actualité également c'était il ya
quatre ans jessica schneider et jean
baptiste salve un couple de policiers
était tué au couteau le 13 juin 2016 à
leur domicile de magnanville un attentat
terroriste par un homme se revendiquant
de l'état islamique
samedi christophe castaner s'est rendu
dans les yvelines pour l'hommage au
commissariat de mantes la jolie où
officiaient est les deux victimes le
ministre de l'intérieur a été accueillie
selon l' afp dans un climat glacial par
une dizaine de policiers en pleine
grogne de la profession suite aux
récentes annonces du gouvernement
symboliquement des menottes ont été
jetés au sol toujours avant que la jolie
c'était fin 2018 l'interpellation de
cent cinquante et une personnes suite
aux manifestations lycéennes à la vidéo
montrant les lycéens genou à terre et
menottées avaient grandement choqué l
enquête sur les conditions de cette
arrestation est aujourd'hui au point
mort le tribunal de nanterre chargé de
l'instruction pour des accusations de
tortures et violences aggravées a estimé
être incompétent
l affaire est donc renvoyée à la
juridiction de versailles l'avocat du
jeune à l'origine de la plainte a déjà
indiqué qu'il comptait faire appel de
cette décision
pour rappel une première plainte déposée
pour violence policière par plusieurs
familles et un syndicat lycéen avait
débouché l'an passé sur un non-lieu
après une enquête préliminaire de l'igpn
la police des polices
trois interpellations dans le cadre de
l' enquête sur l' incendie du chapiteau
de chanteloup-les-vignes la sûreté
départementale des yvelines les a
effectué ce matin
il s'agit de trois hommes de 19 à 23 ans
tous ceux soupçonnés d'être à l'origine
du sinistre
l'un a été arrêté ce matin au quartier
de la noé les deux autres extrait de la
maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy où il
était incarcéré pour d'autres fait le
chapiteau de la compagnie des contraire
avait été détruit par un incendie
criminel dans la nuit du 2 au 3 novembre
[Musique]
mais j - 13 avant le second tour des
élections municipales c'est le 28 juin
prochain à guyancourt
rodolphe baril et la tête de liste
d'ensemble agissons pour guyancourt il
s'est classé deuxième à l'issue du
premier tour nous lui avons donné deux
minutes pour vous convaincre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que c'est une liste indépendante
et l'intérêt communal c'est une liste
représentant toutes les sensibilités et
tous les quartiers et puis c'est aussi
une liste vous présentant la diversité
du en cours alors le point fort de notre
programme ce sont 2 84 engagement 84
engagements qui sont tous documenté qui
sont tous réalisable et qui sont tous
mesurables ils sont répartis en cinq
grands thèmes le carreau de vie
l'écologie l'animation de la ville la
vie municipale
la jeunesse et les seniors et parmi ces
84 engagement on a quelques projets
forts comme la construction d'une
cuisine centrale qui est synonyme de de
maîtrise des approvisionnements circuits
courts et en produits bio également pour
permettre une alimentation beaucoup plus
elle pour l'ensemble de nos écoliers
vous allez également le centre aquatique
on souhaiterait construire un nouveau
centre aquatique dans le quartier dit
des savoirs en remplacement de la
piscine actuelle qui est complètement
sous dimensionné la mise en place aussi
le conseil de quartier parce que c'est
le seul moyen pour nous d'avoir lien
direct avec le quartier est de pouvoir
discuter en allemand de tous les projets
qui concernent les habitants de chaque
quartier
et puis également un autre projet qui
concerne le personnel communal avec la
construction d'un nouveau centre
technique municipal qui sans normes
haute qualité environnementale et qui
permettra une réduction des émissions de
co2 des activités de la municipale
[Applaudissements]
maintenant elle est directement liée à
la crise sanitaire que nous traversons
notre équipe a continué à travailler
pendant sept heures du confinement et il
nous est apparu important que les
premières mesures que nous prendrions
serait la destination les familles
encore tu as alors la première chose
qu'on pressent et mettre en place des
programmes de soutien scolaire pendant
cet été
et puis les activités ludiques parfum
accepté se passe de manière la plus
agréable possible pour les familles du
encore à voisins le bretonneux comme
pour guyancourt les électeurs auront le
choix entre trois candidats pour le
second tour olivier à fons aux têtes de
listes du nid pour voisin était deuxième
au scrutin
après le premier tour présentation
également en deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le plus de ma liste c'est ce sont
les six jeunes qui ont 18 à 24 ans qui
est nous ont rejoints pour faire bouger
les choses
je pense qu'il est essentiel si on veut
construire le voisin de demain est bien
de le construire avec eux mon directeur
de campagne à 21 ans donc j'ai décidé
moi de faire la part belle à la jeunesse
là qui me le rend bien puisque il
apporte des idées nouvelles ils ont une
énergie la débordante moi je suis très
fier de cette équipe le plus c'est
vraiment c'est plutôt un ensemble de
mesures cohérentes mon programme
il vise surtout à agir sur les
principaux problèmes que nous que nous
avons un voisin et ce sont des solutions
concrètes c'était un grand plan sur la
circulation
c'est aussi des mesures comme une
navette électrique pour pouvoir déplacer
nos aînés et les personnes à mobilité
réduite
c'est le passeport culture c'est 50
euros pour les jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent pratiquer une activité sportive
ou culturelle surtout en ces instants de
crise sociale je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de préserver
donner du pouvoir d'achat aux 10 6 mois
et puis aussi on aura aussi à reverdir
notre notre commune qui est de plus en
plus grise donc on aura un grand plan
sur la végétalisation de dans notre
ville
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux décisions la première année
symbolique puisque ça fait très
longtemps que je le demande je
baptiserait le bâtiment de la police
municipale arnaud beltrame
c'est une c'est quelque chose qui me
porte depuis très longtemps et je n'ai
pas été entendu par malheureusement par
la mairie et la décision politique sera
de me réunir de réunir plus tôt les
maires des villes voisines démerdez-vous
guyancourt montigny et manie la vo avec
des représentants de l'agglo du
département et de la région pour mettre
sur la table le sujet de la circulation
qui le le sujet pour moi prioritaires
dans ce prochain mandat
[Applaudissements]
et en complément de ces présentations
nous vous proposons également des débats
en vue du second tour des élections
municipales première émission ce soir à
20 heures avec les candidats de la ville
de plaisir
c'est à voir sur tv 78 à écouter sur les
ondes de nos confrères de radio
sensations yvelines fréquence 98.4 un
mot de ce sport à présent direction
édile de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines sidy diallo un marathonien de
65 ans a parcouru ce dimanche 90 km sur
place le coureur originaire de montigny
le bretonneux à participer virtuellement
en ligne à l'ultra marathon des
camarades en afrique du sud est l'une
des courses les plus longues au monde
annulée cette année en raison de
l'épidémie de coronavirus et mélanie
peau qu'elle a interviewé après une
heure de course
j'espère que ce sera combien de
promenade on veut la dc 10 à 12 heures
normalement ça devrait poser aucun
problème
j'ai déjà fait la course trois fois
l'afrique du sud 1-1 2016 un 2017 et un
2018 et sidy diallo a réussi finalement
son pari la réaliser les 90 km en 10h36
bravo à lui avec la situation épidémique
les médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines vont rouvrir partiellement à
partir de cette semaine vous pourrez
profiter d'un service de drive pour
emprunter des documents dans certaines
médiathèques du réseau quant aux contes
et histoires qui sont à l'accoutumée
déclamer sur place pas de panique il
s'invite à directement chez vous depuis
mercredi dernier plusieurs rendez vous
sont proposés en ligne avec les
bibliothécaires du réseau on en parle
avec marie-pierre caruhel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la responsable de la
politique d'action culturelle pour le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines déjà une
première question pourquoi proposer ces
rendez vous en ligne alors ces rendez
vous en ligne ont été proposés à la
suite du confinement pour confinement 1
2 mois sans le public sans pouvoir
proposer en direct des comptes comme on
en a l'habitude et le plaisir d'en
proposer et donc les bibliothécaires se
sont mobilisés pendant cette période
pour proposer des solutions en ligne
alors on aurait pu on aurait pu se
précipiter sur nos smartphones sur nos
tablettes pour proposer des solutions
pour moi le confinement c'est pas le
choix qu'on a opéré un contrairement il
y avait beaucoup de propositions en
ligne déjà sur cette période on a
préféré prendre le temps nous organiser
et proposer une solution de qualité
cirque on a vraiment des films qui ont
été réalisés par des professionnels de
l'image et donc une solution qui pourra
être pérenne
c'est une solution que nous proposons
actuellement jusqu'à la réouverture
pleine et entière des médiathèques
puisque le service public fait
partiellement proposé là avec une
proposition de greffe et médiathèque
vont rouvrir progressivement
à partir de juillet l'action culturelle
en elle-même ne va pas reprendre tout de
suite
donc on espère pouvoir reprendre
normalement au programme à partir de
septembre c'est pas le cas donc on va
proposer ses comptes en ligne à raison
d'un calendrier de manière un peu comme
comme d'habitude ils vont parler juste
dans un instant on a compris que c'était
très progressive jusqu'au bout pour
savoir ce qui était proposé d'habitude
aux médiathèques ses heures de contes
s'étaient proposés directement sur place
en paierez la normale avant l'avant le
confinement c'est comme ça que ça se
déroule tout à fait d'habitude dans
chaque médiathèque
enfin sur les douze médiathèque de saint
quentin vous pouvez assister à des
heures du conte pour les petits pour les
grands selon un calendrier est aux
manières régulier c'est vraiment le
rendez-vous des médiathèques habituel et
c'est un rendez-vous qui manquait aux
enfants aux parents ils vous ont fait
remonter cette envie de revoir les
comptes réapparaître d'une certaine
manière la sas est proposé en ligne est
ce qu'il ya eu une attente de la part
des parents et des enfants
il l'attend l'essentiel est quand même
sur le service public sur la proposition
des documents de pouvoir emprunter des
documents je pense que c'est la tante
essentiel maintenant on a eu des retours
très positifs depuis la mise en ligne de
ces comptes puisque nous avons déjà eu
la leur tour par exemple d'une
assistante maternelle d'un papa qui nous
dit que c'était vraiment formidable
comme avait proposé dirais que c'est
plus une satisfaction tu n'as n'attend
vraiment crucial on peut comprendre que
c'est un peu la problématique aussi de
deux des solutions en ligne il ya
pléthore de solutions maintenance qui va
faire notre différence c'est que les
enfants qui ont l'habitude de voir
certaines bibliothèques à vont pouvoir
retrouver les visages des visages
familiers
c'est s'appelait différence par rapport
à une offre
tu ne serais pas locale mais et vous le
disiez ce sont des vidéos
professionnelles avec de l'image en plus
des comptes est aussi bas les
bibliothécaires vous en parliez qui ont
été mis à contribution les
bibliothécaires du réseau des
médiathèques
oui tout à fait les écarts se sont
mobilisés c'est vraiment une aile une
attente très forte qu'elle avait de
pouvoir faire cette proposition à leur
public
donc on a une dizaine de bibliothèques
garder jacques et son big listière pour
pour participer à ces séances de contes
alors trois ont déjà été mises en ligne
depuis mercredi dernier
l'idée c'est vous en parliez tout à
l'heure de les proposer régulièrement
jusqu'à une certaine période le caler le
calendrier
justement actuellement nous sommes nous
proposer en trois contes par semaine
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août au mois
dire que tant que les médiathèques ne
sont pas ouvertes nous nous proposerons
cette offre en ligne et nous la
garderons sire que les comptes sont
dévoilés progressivement toutes les
semaines vous allez trois rendez vous
par semaine et pour les comptes en fait
qui restent libres de droit donc à
savoir aller qu'on les comptines jeux de
doigts
les contes traditionnels tous ses
comptes vont être proposées aussi sur le
portail des médiathèques vous pourrez
avoir accès au delà de la période de
programmation assez assez assez compte
via le portail i médiathèque avec une
page dédiée spéciale pour ses comptes en
ligne mais j'allais vous demander quels
étaient les comptes mise en ligne est ce
que il ya des comptes qui se prêtent
plus facilement à cet exercice de les
dire en ligne finalement est ce que il
ya une sélection qui a été fait pour
pour cette mise en ligne alors la
sélection n'a pas été différent de celle
que l'on propose d'habitude y mènent des
collègues ont essayé de retrouver
l'interactivité qu'on a d'habitude avec
un public présent avec des comptines par
exemple on peut répéter à la suite de la
bibliothécaire vous avez des décomptes
qui sont dit vous avez des livres qui
sont lus et dans ces cas là on a aussi
l'image du livre qui est accessible et
qui est incrusté en fait des limites en
image et donc au fur et à mesure que la
bibliothèque à raconte vous avez aussi
les images du livre qui s'affiche et ils
vous le disais donc trois rendez vous
par semaine là le prochain c
alors le prochain c'est mercredi mardi
matin pour les petits pour les petits là
on vous attend dès mercredi matin et
tous ses comptes a retrouvé bien sûr sur
le portail i médiathèque merci marie
pierre caruhel d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous et je rappelle que vous
êtes à la responsable de la politique
d'action culturelle pour le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines avant de vous quitter il était
dans les yvelines en fin de semaine
dernière le duo de rappeurs toulousain
un big flo et oli a tourné son dernier
clip insolent 4 à carrières sous poissy
est deux jours de tournage sur place à
la carrière de la ville et boulevard
pelletier qui a été fermée à la
circulation pour l'occasion les artistes
comme vous le voyez sur cette faute ont
été ensuite reçus à la mairie par
christophe delrieu le maire de carrières
sous poissy
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]